merci beaucoup merci madame la Première
ministre chère Elisabeth merci d'être
présente maintenant et comme tu l'as été
hier soir c'est important pour nous et
vraiment Gifi extrêmement sensible merci
cher Yaël pour tes mots qui me touche
profondément je suis très heureux de
pouvoir travailler avec toi tu as raison
on est souvent d'accord ensemble parfois
on ne sera pas d'accord ensemble mais on
pourra toujours le faire en franchise et
on trouvera toujours une voix ensemble
je voudrais aussi remercier messieurs et
mesdames les ministres d'être présent
avec nous de pouvoir montrer évidemment
de discuter avec l'ensemble des députés
et d'être peut-être présent au quotidien
je passe un petit message je crois qu'il
fera plaisir aussi à certains ne nous
oubliez pas quand vous venez dans les
circonscriptions pensez pensez à appeler
les députés on vous le dit on vous le
redit ça devrait être le premier réflexe
Pierre-François merci pour beaucoup pour
tes mots pour ta présence tout toutes
les deux jours ça me touche je sais que
tu es en campagne pour les autres et
nous sommes tous tes mots je peux les
reprendre alors que nous clôturons ces
journées parlementaires je voudrais
juste un mot remercier l'ensemble des
équipes du groupe Renaissance nos
collaborateurs qui travaillent comme des
fous et qui ont permis la réussite de
ces journées merci merci beaucoup
il est hyper engagé et je suis très fier
de pouvoir travailler avec vous comme le
son tous les députés je voudrais aussi
avoir un mot pour mon ami Aurore berger
c'est dans le président de groupe j'ai
adoré travailler avec toi tu le sais je
voulais le dire et le redire et je crois
que le groupe tu as permis de franchir
un cap nous ne sommes plus perçus comme
des godillots nous ne sommes plus perçus
loin d'une indépendance par rapport avec
le gouvernement en un an et je vais
m'inscrire dans tes pas merci encore
pour le travail en commun
[Applaudissements]
le temps de partage que nous venons de
vivre nous a permis de réfléchir en
commun d'ouvrir de nouvelles
perspectives lors des plénières et
ateliers mais surtout d'échanger et se
retrouver il faut désormais continuer
sur cette lancée car nous savons dans
quelques jours une rentrée parlementaire
pleine de défis nous attend nous venons
d'avoir quelques mots dessus nous y
sommes préparés et le groupe Renaissance
sera agir en responsabilité pour
continuer à saisir nos finances en
débutant avec le vote des textes de loi
budgétaires qui rythmeront ce semestre
pour permettre à chaque Français de
bénéficier d'un travail et d'atteindre
ensemble notre objectif le plein emploi
ou encore pour apporter davantage de
sécurité aux utilisateurs de l'espace
numérique qui a trop longtemps été à
considéré comme une zone de non-droits
nous venons d'avoir une plénière
d'ailleurs sur l'intelligence
artificielle je crois que ça nous
éclaire aussi sur le chemin à suivre
autant de projets de loi sur lequel nous
serons être force de proposition et de
co-construction
sur les chantiers présents comme à venir
madame la Première ministre chère
Elisabeth tu pourras toujours compter
sur le soutien des députés Renaissance
ils ne t'ont jamais fait défaut
car oui au cours de cette année notre
groupe est ton gouvernement ont su mené
ensemble les combats politiques
nécessaires pour la réussite de notre
pays au premier rang desquels la réforme
des retraites cela a été dur c'est vrai
que ça a été dur mais nous avons dû
lutter contre la démagogie de certains
et contre l'attentisme de l'eau des
autres mais nous avons tenu pour
préserver notre système de pension et
faire en sorte que dans 20 ans 30 ans
les Français et les Françaises puissent
bénéficier d'une retraite descente cela
aucun de nos adversaires ne pourra nous
l'enlever
au travers de ces nombreuses réformes
menées en commun c'était établi entre le
gouvernement et notre groupe une
relation franche exigeante bien sûr mais
toujours loyal en tant que président de
groupe je m'attacherai à ce que ce lien
demeure toujours aussi fort nous sommes
unis par un même but celui de
concrétiser dans tous les domaines le
projet tracé par le Président de la
République
notre cheminement commun continue
d'avoir pour fil rouge la promesse de
celle pour laquelle nous nous sommes
engagés aux côtés d'Emmanuel Macron
celle qui incarne celle qui s'incarne
dans les mots libérés et protégés mais
aussi dans la valeur travail
celle qui existe de donner à chacun les
moyens de son émancipation en refusant
la fatalité face aux déterminisme et les
phrases toutes faites du style c'est
comme ça et ça ne changera jamais nous
continuerons toujours à penser à dire et
à prouver par notre action que tous ces
préjugés sont faux
car les députés Renaissance ont
démontrés au cours de cette première
année qu'ils ont toutes leurs places
pour proposer un soufflet et mener les
transformations nécessaires pour les
Françaises et les Français cet élan
comptez sur moi pour le faire perdurer
et l'amplifier
rien que cette année avec les parties de
la majorité présidentielle nous avons
voté une hausse inédite des moyens de
notre justice de notre police cher
générale de notre défense nous avons
aussi renforcé notre sécurité
énergétique en relançant la grande
aventure du nucléaire français et
favoriser la réindustrialisation de
notre pays à travers l'investissement
dans la transition écologique le groupe
Renaissance a également pleinement usé
de son droit d'initiative parlementaire
pour faire voter des textes marquants
c'est le cas avec la loi contre
l'occupation illicite des logements qui
a permis de mieux réglementer la
location immobilière c'est aussi le cas
avec la loi pour un meilleur accès aux
soins qui contribue à la revalorisation
des professions de santé que notre
majorité met en place depuis trois ans
mais encore avec la Loire renforçant le
droit à l'image de nos enfants qui
permettra une fois adopter de mieux
protéger les plus jeunes contre le les
dangers des réseaux sociaux
je pourrais en citer beaucoup d'autres
la loi sur le temps d'écran des enfants
celle pour un Erasmus de l'apprentissage
j'y suis très attaché celle pour un
accès facilité au permis de conduire ou
encore celle pour mieux réglementer les
centres de santé sur le territoire
notre groupe a même élaboré la première
loi transpartie avec la loi sur les
influenceurs qui vient réguler toute une
profession Yelle tu as raison il faut
aller plus vers le transpartisan
voilà autant d'avancer concrète qui
doivent être suivi de beaucoup d'autres
dans notre groupe regorge de talent et
l'idée au cours des 4 ans à venir nous
entendons continuer avec cette même
boussole cela passe également par
s'assurer que les voient votées
bénéficient le plus rapidement possible
aux citoyens avec le fameux dernier
kilomètre qui doit être notre objectif
constant
notre ambition de mieux légiférer elle
est bien supermise par le lien de
confiance mutuelle que nous entretenons
avec nos partenaires de la majorité que
sont les groupes démocrates et horizons
je veux les saluer à cette occasion
c'est notre travail en commun qui permet
le plus souvent à notre assemblée de
prendre toute sa place qui est la sienne
aussi bien dans le rôle de législateur
que dans celui de contrôle de l'action
du gouvernement
mais cette ambition passe aussi par une
plus grande mise en avant du travail
transpartisan dont nous venons de parler
en aiguisant l'assemblée qui est la
nôtre pour cette 16e législature les
Françaises et les Français nous ont
envoyé un message clair ils nous ont
désignés comme la majorité la plus apte
à gouvernement a gouverner il n'y a pas
d'autres majorité que la nôtre mais
aussi comme celle capable de tisser les
ponts entre les différentes forces de
l'hémicycle
comme la majorité qui n'usse pas de
démagogie ou de faux-semblants comme
celles qui ose s'attaquer au sujet
sensible par les réformes nécessaires là
où d'autres ne proposeront jamais rien
de viable
l'initiative prise par le Président de
la République de réunir les parties les
chefs des partis politiques dont tu as
parlé tout à l'heure François il y a
quelques jours à Saint-Denis le prouve
encore la transition écologique ne
devrait pas être un sujet de division la
préservation de notre modèle social ne
devrait pas être prétexte à discension
la place de la France dans le monde
l'ordre républicain l'école laïque ne
devrait jamais être des objets de
discorde
il faut que nous soyons collectivement
capables d'échanger et de co-construire
sur des sujets aussi fondamentaux pour
les notre pays
le groupe des députés Renaissance y est
prêt dans un esprit constructif en
accord avec nos idées et nos valeurs
je le dis à ce pupitre nous saurons
toujours ouverts au compromis
mais jamais en acceptant les
compromissions et donc je souhaite que
nous puissions avancer dans cette
démarche transpartisane en étant capable
de prendre les bonnes idées là où elle
se trouve mais sans jamais jamais nous
rogner
allons au-delà même des semaines
transpartisanes imaginées par Yaël
contribuant à faire de ce dialogue
transpartisan non pas une exception mais
une règle tacite de fonctionnement de
notre assemblée
car il ne sera pas dit que nous avons
été de ceux qui s'enferment dans le
sectarisme
en restant sourd aux attentes exprimées
très clairement par les Françaises et
les Français
je sais pouvoir compter mes chers
collègues sur chacun d'entre vous pour
faire preuve dans vos responsabilités de
président de rapporteurs de responsables
de textes et plus globalement de
législateur de cet esprit de consensus
qui a toujours caractérisé notre
mouvement
cet esprit de dialogue que nous
souhaitons insuffler au sein de
l'assemblée sera plus que nécessaire
pour faire avancer les grands sujets qui
nous attendent
le débat autour des conditions de la fin
de vie la nécessaire discussion sur
notre politique migratoire
l'apport de solutions viable face à la
crise du logement que connaît notre pays
enfin la concrétisation d'une société du
Bien Vieillir autant d'urgence sur
lesquelles nous devons afficher un
message d'unité
notre groupe est riche de diversité
sociale professionnelle générationnelle
sachons exploiter cette force sans
jamais privilégier les individualisme et
sans jamais sombrer dans une fausse
unité ou dans une unité qui n'est pas
pleinement assumée
car à l'instar de ce qui se passe quand
nous sommes dans l'hémicycle c'est en
restant uni que nous sommes forts en
nous dispersant que nous avons nous
faisons aveu de faiblesse
retenez ceci aucune voix ne porte si
elle est isolée
chers collègues chers amis nous sommes
la représentation nationale que les
Français ont élu et ré élus soyons en
fiers aussi de ce que nous avons réalisé
et ce qui reste nous reste à accomplir
ensemble et surtout osons notre ADN
c'est l'audace alors osons la discussion
quand c'est possible et la confrontation
lorsque c'est nécessaire
osons innover dans nos pratiques comme
dans nos idées
plus que tout
osons être nous-mêmes le parti des
solutions là où tant d'autres ne font
que pointer des problèmes le parti des
actes quand d'autres se contentent de
parole le parti du changement quand
d'autres souhaitent l'immobilisme c'est
fort de la confiance que vous m'avez
témoigné en médisant comme président de
groupe que je m’emploierai à ce que les
députés Renaissance demeurent ce qu'ils
sont depuis six ans le moteur du progrès
social le moteur du progrès économique
et écologique le moteur du progrès
sociétal dans notre pays je compte sur
vous vous pouvez compter sur moi je vous
remercie